[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
and now for the adventures of the white
privilege boy
hey buddies what do you want to do today
you you want to go down to the arcade
and play pinball
no
i know how about we play uh hide and
seek we did that last week hi no want to
take our accurate to replica bb guns and
commit an armed robbery yeah that's it
that sounds fun let's do it all right
let's do it yeah oh those boys what
pickle will they find themselves in next
stay tuned for next week's installment
of adventures of the white privilege
boys louder with crowder is brought to
you in part by.com
head over to the shop support the fight
and buy some cool threads
it's the tits pajamas.com
[Music]
[Music]
um
is
[Music]
that was uh that was wonderful that was
a that was a condolences uh sip for our
viewers in new jersey who still live in
hell
that was gonna happen sorry apologies
sorry for that
something about 3 a.m i don't know post
dating uh we have a lot to talk about
today
some updates on the cal written house uh
trial and by updates i mean some
information that you already know but
you get to see the surprise faces on
prosecution and everybody who didn't
actually follow the news or watch the
footage uh we have a seven seven plus
one actually we have exclusive uh alec
baldwin excuses oh okay good for uh you
know murder rampage and i just i'm
letting you know uh ahead of time we are
going to be talking about because of the
swing now with female voters and was
trending yesterday white women if you
want to go check that out on twitter
just to get your dose of racism for the
day
um i feel bad about humanity there's the
golden penis syndrome it happens to
coincide was written about at new york
post okay maybe it was a washington post
uh column i'm not entirely sure but
there's a real problem now where women
are finding themselves a lot of you out
there finding yourself unhappy
um and i think look i'm front loading
this here which is what my therapist
says you know like like hey sweetie i
know you're great at decorating uh the
house and i appreciate uh the women's
touch and make a house a home but i hate
those nights says this to you yes yeah
by the way i'm sorry can you say the
name of this syndrome again i'm sorry i
i i have misheard golden penis syndrome
yes gold gold it's gold i love gold but
uh look
remember oh i am letting you know uh
women right now if you're watching
listening this is uh something that i
know i've called men to the mat
for
being fatherless uh sorry being not
being fathers for creating fatherless
homes for not being responsible for this
this feminization of men and men not
taking their leadership role
um seriously and and leading their
families and there is this so i hope you
understand that this all comes from a
place of love same thing with women
let's we had we had some we had some
some real wins going on there this week
let's try and build some mail some real
momentum with that okay so
we're gonna be talking about that uh but
first joel day how are you i am well
speaking of his best dad ever best dad
ever yeah i mean i i just i it found me
now is it libel or slander if it's
written
that's mean quarter black garrett how
are you good morning what's going on
yeah once you have a chicago bulls
and this is i've never ever been to
chicago it's back when they were good
yeah yeah yeah i'm a fan of the you know
the michael jordan oh could you not be i
don't know so you're not a lebron guy
no no no no i'm a magic johnson guy
straight as an arrow and he will be
at uh the cotillion oh wichita kansas
november 11th this weekend in
philadelphia go see him it's
life-changing uh dave landau how are you
yes ahoy i'm good i realize uh in the
camera now that i should have just
buttoned the top button yeah and thrown
on some sunglasses like avatar oh yeah
what are you auditioning for eddie bauer
here today i've uh edward james almost
casting
american me i love how you said a
vatican yeah
i don't understand the reference i
respect uh mexican gangsters
you mess with those people right yeah
yeah
cartels they mean business oh we'll also
talk about aaron rodgers that's gerald
oh yeah uh immunization versus
vaccination it's a difference this is
something that you know now because of
the cdc and changing definitions uh
doesn't mean anything not anymore so we
find another excuse people find another
excuse to screech about it yeah
well he's gonna miss some time no i was
immunized mr building
uh so by the way also if you are
watching right now we never know with uh
with the youtube
it's a live show monday through thursday
you can watch us if you don't see it
here you can watch it on rumble okay you
can watch it on mug club the show goes
on it just may not be on youtube we
don't know how to tell you any more
effectively uh than that okay before we
go on to everything else let's watch
this um another video from libs of tick
tock they do some good work they do this
type of woman
wants to
actually and i know i don't mean when i
say literally i don't mean that
figuratively
oh like most people yeah
oh literally wants to kill the unvaxxed
what yeah yeah yeah uh just this is it's
uh it's amy schumer got into a particle
accelerator and joined weight watchers
here so finally some good news
uh kids can get the vaccine five and up
starting next week come on that's great
news
and uh as soon as these guys can get it
too
all bets are off
you anna baxter's all bets are off
if i can spread it like annoyingly after
that
um
i'm going to sneeze on yeah a lot of you
oh
attempted murder all bets are off
because we're all done we're all done
with you so as soon as these guys
can be safe
screw the rest of you she looks like
she's about to eat him
sad thing is some of your kids you'll
float too but i hope they don't
maybe they'll just take your kids from
you that'd be good oh wow yeah well you
know what how about this you first
what an awful [ __ ]
yeah there's really no other way to no
sorry i didn't sorry not accurate but
you know i'm right i'm going to spit on
you well look first off we're not i'm
not afraid of you spitting on me because
of the covet but because of everything
else you have yeah it's what what yeah
what do you think will happen if the
government starts showing up at people's
doors trying to take their children for
not being vaccinated against covet 19.
and and just do me a favor and go to the
cdc website and just look up the stats
i'm not even going to mention them here
just go just go do some research on the
government they wouldn't even show up
with guns anymore they would just show
up with her as a rifle and elmer fudd
would straighten out bugs bunny
yeah you might hand over your kids if
you have to talk to her for 20 minutes
yeah you're like i just preemptively
like that's true and i love my kids but
if she showed up i would go all right
here they go my son would be like the
kitten hook you didn't even try it
and you're like yeah no you're right do
you like reach out and touch your
father's hand peter i didn't even cry
but that's sad i don't know what we're
allowed to say in here this sucks i
don't know we're allowed to say on
youtube but don't worry we'll be on
we'll be on mug club after okay let's
just say hypothetically yeah if she had
this vaccine
what's the problem
right
yeah no she can still get sick and she
can still spread it oh still be
hospitable that seems odd yeah yeah yeah
so in other words she's spitting on
everyone else just to make our
likelihood of contracting kova the same
as hers i think she just wants to shut
up
maybe spit on people yeah well look it's
a kink spit's not enough
what is this dune and she's sharing her
body moisture with us
[Applause]
it's a good film
bit
yeah visually stunning for crying out
loud i'm gonna spit on you maybe take
your kids that'll be nice
look women and this is what i'm gonna
talk with you about later do you see are
you starting to get the picture do you
see what's happening do you see how the
left has taken you for granted they
thought that all you cared about was
your vagina was abortion do you see
they're coming after your kids
they're coming after your kids and by
the way it was overwhelmingly men who
opposed putting kids on puberty blockers
look at the custody battles it's the
father saying no no we're going too far
when you open that door
women like this can come in and spit on
you and take your kids if they don't
take a vaccine which by the way
internationally is is not agreed upon as
a matter of fact the agreement is that
now we don't need to be vaccinating
five-year-olds right in other countries
of course the united states
has gotten it right right and you should
give it to all fetuses she's correct
well she's got to be a grandmother right
there's no way
because of the you see her because pitch
needs to moisturize oh there's no way
that's the mom no i oh i think it was
the mom her womb is the sahara yes oh
come on
what look it's like
her womb is dune
directed by david lynch yeah oh yeah
that one for sure
yeah oh yeah it would be that one yeah
she's definitely got a lynch woman yeah
it's a dystopian future womb yes that
was filmed in detroit yeah there's just
one baby the eraser had babies from the
room it's just a just a fetus and all
just a fetus like no no all the
antibodies show up like that first scene
in robocop
mommy loves you
no you don't okay
hey by speaking which why are why are do
do
two women out this is my question today
um
because i know there's been a divide
among women but also women are nicer
than men and so you've been way more
tolerant of feminist [ __ ] than you
should be do you acknowledge now that
feminist [ __ ] have ruined a lot for
the rest of you out there like it's it's
time to clean house i really hope that
we continue this after virginia
overwhelming repudiation and here it
took it took women going from i want to
be a working professional and i met
women can do everything men can do to
mama bear that's what happened in
virginia yeah exactly it switched back
and if it continues in any way shape or
form 2022 is going to be a landslide
yeah yep and it should keep it going by
the way you can also follow us on tik
tock before we move on that's where all
the chai comms are no doubt will be
banned again you gotta play that uh yeah
we're gonna be taking your live chat
later it's super chat thursday oh yeah
that's right but uh this is another
thing you know uh former vice president
joe biden
um he had one of those breakthrough
poopings
oh cool yeah yeah despite uh despite
having a fecal transplant you had one of
the breakthrough self-soiling really
yeah but it's worse he lost another uh
bodily function no swallowing
which brings us to this week in biden
wait if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump and you
ain't black that approximately excuse me
i'm gonna pick your part i swallowed it
wrong
wait if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump then you
ain't black i'm sorry did that senator
just say he swallowed wrong
sucker can you breathe
dave no what did what careful dave we
are on you no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no dave stop stop hey
we get it that it writes itself tantrum
oh you wonder why china doesn't respect
us
[Applause]
don't know how to swallow oh yeah maybe
next time chew gum and walk at the same
time haha mr man no swaddle what do you
do
i held it in i didn't spit it out that's
a good job actually i mean
oh yeah your country with myanmar with
president who can't swallow
it's good he's drinking what is he
drinking is it nyquil
just like immediately like green stuff
i feel better now ah this guy put me out
right after this and i'm gonna wake up
and not know who i am until someone
reminds me i'm president
those ten seconds before i figured that
out or glow it's like 50 first dates he
has to like retail
every time he wakes up remember how
angry they were that uh donald trump one
time had a shaky hand when he had to
drink water which can happen to anyone
who has a flu anyone who's sick you know
anyone who has something
injury yeah it could have worked out
that day yeah exactly yeah listen it's
just i worked the buys
and i got the head of the tries with the
buys and so i need to hold this now
because
it's all the lactic acid buildup that is
your kid swallow
oh he's alright mr brother and cancer
swaddle here in china we have swaddle
bird you can't even go
do you think he's sitting around
watching tv like i lost to that guy yeah
but every single time like yeah well it
was the most legitimate election
history he lost the most very fair
secure
election of all time
because all major uh metropolitan areas
are determined at 3 30 a.m all right it
is time for you know this has been
everywhere aaron rodgers and i know
nothing about the uh athletic endeavors
time for gerald no sports
[Music]
okay so geraldine correct me if i have
this uh right okay aaron rodgers you
have it right not aaron
he's a player correct he is he is a huge
door
he's uh he's a player did you say oh
he's a player
he's a star quarterback in the nfl but
perhaps one of the best in history next
to tom brady okay a couple of other guys
and he has been ruled out oh it's very
sad day for sunday's game versus the
kansas city chiefs uh and he was
supposed to play against one of the very
best quarterbacks in the league and so
everybody was looking for it's like a
dream match-up yeah exactly like in mma
it's like george st pierre fighting
somebody like today who's amazing yes
and you just everybody wants to see it
cathy ireland pillow fighting so patrick
mahomes is a quarterback and and it's
just not going to happen these guys
don't really play each other very often
but he was asked this summer so he's out
because of a positive test for cove the
nfl has stupid rules about it but he was
asked this summer about his
vaccinations exactly
spit on him
she did we should look into that maybe
maybe we can find some uh high-res
footage you know that's the problem with
these these these women they don't they
don't know who they hurt well you got to
listen to you got to listen to his
response she said baby is the football
help it yeah
get it out of that home so so here's
you're going to like this about aaron
here's his response when asked about his
vaccination status okay any conversation
are you vaccinated and what's your
stance on vaccinations yeah i've been
immunized okay hold on hold on hold on
before you say anything else
that is 19d chess that's a guy who knows
how to swallow properly
because he said immunized
he said immunized that is the term that
was used forever all the shots that we
got as kids right it was the cdc that
changed it with the covid vaccine
because it doesn't immunize you this is
the previous definition was a product
that stimulates a person's immune system
to produce immunity to specific disease
protecting the person from that disease
the new definition is a preparation that
is used to stimulate the body's immune
response against diseases so it protects
against now it's not immunized so that
was some clever wordplay we literally
had to change the definition because of
i mean covetous had a lot of effects it
just changed the definition of words
unfortunately people are spitting on me
wherever i walk well that's true i mean
but that's that's their them being nice
to you yeah yeah
apparently roger's long before covet yes
yeah well you never i mean he was trying
to build his immune system the more it's
a cat calling
yeah
that's a signal yeah a bad signal it's
funny when he tries to catch it in his
mouth every single time i have no idea
why you know
it's a skill it'd be wrong to waste yeah
what do you want to hit the ground yeah
well true but look apparently aaron
rodgers received a homeopathic treatment
from his personal life
stop it the nfl does not count that as
being vaccinated well that's fair that's
true i'll give them that nfl policy says
an unvaccinated player has to isolate
after a positive test for 10 days
unvaccinated players also have to test
every single day and by the way when
they travel with the team if you're
unvaccinated you actually don't get to
travel with the team you have to travel
separately and then you have to test
before you rejoin the team and you can't
hang out with the team in the hotel it's
ridiculous their policies are absolutely
stupid well i understand that if you
test positive you shouldn't be able to
no no if you're unvaccinated well hold
on if you test positive okay was he not
out on the field practicing with people
like was he not like face to face with
people all that's a trick question
you'll like this there's some
information about aaron rodgers that i
think we're gonna get to the bottom of
here so he he's refused to take the
vaccine apparently and i'm thinking he
might actually be secretly based
[Music]
there's way too much work for that
stinger it really is but it's not very
detailed yeah i like it it's good so
isn't he married to that is it well one
second is he married to that crazy broad
shailene woodley who like who thinks she
thinks deodorant is a government form of
mind control she thinks that like the
firefighters have a switch they flip to
chemtrails well pretty engaged that's
right and he's still got time to back
out right let's give him some credit for
that but i think i think a map to our
crazies that's a fair point but a fault
in our crazy sorry the map to our hey no
backing out they're married they're
actually married oh my gosh never mind
also that's their that's his form of
birth there goes uh my homeopathic
no i do other than that i think i have
some pretty that he's secretly based
pretty solid evidence yeah i need to see
these
um i do feel confident things i say and
i do stand behind what i do
and i like to speak the truth and i'm
not a part of this uh
you know uh woke uh
cancel culture that
gets off on uh trying to silence people
all the time confirmed it looks like
three guys that are gonna rob a train
[Laughter]
the title was way too long on that one
yeah now one guy is the one who looks
like he got his things shot off in pulp
fiction who's in a little bit scumbag
or they could be a lacrosse team yeah
that's true yeah
big night for the duke lacrosse team
all right let's
wrap this up here joe two weeks ago
aaron rodgers says that he is he is
absolutely 100 percent secretly based
and that's why they're going after them
and that's why they're going out all
right i think you're right that makes
sense gerald does know sports
oh is that the yeah we don't care
[Music]
all right now onto stuff that matters oh
stop it all you men who wear another
man's name on your back did he pin you
with his class ring oh shut up you're
dead it's not gay at all to support your
team no no no no no no tell us more
about mma and the heterosexuality of it
yeah oh i have knowledge yes
yes it's not blatantly it's not latently
homosexual it's blatantly completely
yeah north south is what position again
stephen yeah north south is his head and
crotch ah yes both ways
we call that 69 in the dayton game yeah
that's what they call it yeah well i
should tell you about turtle
so
that's just a tuesday night in the
bootage family yeah oh well yeah well
not so much lower not so much anymore
it's hard when you're breastfeeding so
you gotta keep it you gotta spice it up
he's drinking a lot of milk trying to
make milk not working
he's just mixing hops in uh similac
[Music]
just gross
save
the babies
skeletons and cuffs men can have milk
ducks yeah they can yeah there was a
rumor that uh i won't you know it's i
mean that's a that's a medical condition
there's a rumor that steven
used to uh lactate produce when he was
uh uh aroused really yes i don't know
i bet it's true it's gotta be true
listen when i lactate
bad things happen
[Laughter]
high protein levels
i have registered lethal weapon hands
yes that's why i have to be very careful
when i eat in public
also not allowed to carry these hands
into an establishment that makes more
than 50
of the profit off alcohol
because it's like i'm carrying do you
see what i'm saying
i have a great ponytail and i can feed
your baby with my ninja tits
[Laughter]
what a worthless man
you and i watch what was it
what was that which was it dmx it was
dmx it was written by a four-year-old
yeah we left so the greatest line ever
they go into like
yeah it's like ten minutes of them
looking over security camera footage
right and steven's sorry we're gonna get
to cal written house in a little bit
this is totally relevant yeah was it is
it exit wounds with dmx
yes i don't know what we were thinking
yeah but i think we ordered halal guys
and watched exit wounds what and
there's i'll set it up
are you serious all the other characters
in the film are going over security
camera footage it was like a bank oh
yeah they're looking at like the kind of
watch he has what time it was like yeah
being very detailed they're like oh he
has this kind of watch well if that's a
fake he only could have picked it up in
23rd and 4th or whatever and they're
going through all these details on the
security camera footage to try and
identify the thief and after about five
minutes steven seagal speaks up hand to
god
he's black
[Laughter]
good calls steve's dmx it's like we just
both laughed for ten minutes because
like everybody in the room is gonna go
yeah yeah thanks
dude he's acting like he figured out
he's black oh my god stephen why don't
you go teach us how to run yeah yes
why don't you ask usain bolt i taught
him everything he knew oh sid you i'm
going
wear a vest with no shirt under it and
play a little guitar do you guys mind oh
and uh i'm gonna cut two holes in the
vest just because uh it gets heavy yes
so um i'm gonna feed your baby without
my nipple
ninja ninja what if he was called by the
butt giggs that's a midwife
he probably was
you check that baby
i'll deliver that you will you're high
milk you have to find a male nipple in
him i've delivered thousands of babies
i've delivered thousands of babies and
killed many chickens
given a c-section just by going like
this oh my god yes i look at him and
he's circumcised
why are you looking at baby penis no i
don't you
[Laughter]
i said the wrong thing he's pouring
bleach on top that's not oxygen powder
it doesn't work this is facebook he's
calling the customer service live hilary
hello guy with beard from oxyclean
[Laughter]
there's still kitty porn on my imac and
i've bleached it twice
i need a sham
wow i've been scouting circumcisions
again all right well then
while you're there get me jack the lane
i could use a juicer so uh
put on a little few put on a few pounds
pandemic
so okay so this is what's going on with
cal rittenhouse all right this is
important here because if you're looking
at the leftist media you will notice a
trend
they are admitting they were wrong about
everything because they know they can be
sued now so i have seen multiple outlets
saying it was initially reported that he
uh he had taken weapons across state
lines we were incorrect yeah because you
were the ones who initially reported it
so there was we initially reported that
uh rose and uh rosenbaum was being
chased by cal right now so we now know
that that is incorrect yes because
you're the ones who made it up
there was plenty of footage available
however there is more footage that was
made available we did our stream you can
go and watch it for four and a half
hours we covered the opening statements
um
here's the thing there's there's a new
report that shows the the fbi had
hd uh well hd version of the footage
that we showed on and we're gonna show
it to you again uh that they did not
give the defense and they may have
destroyed
so keep this in mind i'm about to show
you this footage the prosecuting
attorney
said there's fbi footage too that the
public has not seen which we think will
show that uh rittenhouse was chasing
rosenbaum uh first off
why was that not given to the defense
that's not how this is with evidence
that's how it's absolutely supposed to
happen why did the fbi withhold this
information and by the way it doesn't
help the prosecution at all when you
watch this it's very very clear that
kyle rittenhouse was chased into a kill
trap by rosenbaum and the the man who
fired the first shot
this is the kind of footage that the fbi
was sitting on that could easily result
in the dismissal of all charges
exoneration and hopefully an apology the
fbi is not your friend the fbi is using
this as a political tool they had this
footage this whole time if they were
interested in making sure that the
guilty are put behind bars and that the
innocent go free this is something that
not only would have been in line with
precedent as far as presenting evidence
yeah both sides
in a court case need to be able to
review all evidence but it also would be
the right thing to do so um here's the
non-hd version which is heavily edited
the only one that exists according to
the fbi which we played on tuesday
so you see
they're yelling get him get him get him
rittenhouse is saying friendly friendly
friendly
and that is rosenbaum who now runs out
from behind the car see the chase kyle
rittenhouse do you see that right there
he's clearly chasing kyle house
and his
rosenbaum's last words keep in mind
serial pedophile to an un to a minor
were
[ __ ] you yeah nice how's that for irony
yeah by the way so so there's context
here too in that last part of the video
you forgot to say i want to [ __ ] me
totally no no no no no [ __ ] you
i mean will you
just for context he was running between
cars on the other side of those cars was
an even larger crowd of people
and you could see the guy chasing him
rosa's mom closing the distance well
what you can see is kyle right now says
running he's trying to see rosenbaum go
between the cars that's where he puts a
face covering on a t-shirt whatever it
is we don't know why could be to cover
his identity could be because all of a
sudden he's like oh covet's still real
yeah and then he decides to run around
the car and chase him so from behind
yeah from behind and then a gunshot is
fired and the guy is yelling get him get
him get him and rosenbaum's last words
are [ __ ] you as cal rittenhouse turns
around and hears gunshots come on guys
and this is something that the fbi
always had access to yeah and by the way
when asked about this the fbi said that
they um
lost yeah whoops we lost it well look
you're either incompetent or dishonest
take your pick but uh
you shouldn't be in charge of anything
folks no and for those of you who watch
cnn i don't know why um if you were
watching it just a second ago as we
intro this story they were showing that
same footage but their lower third said
new footage release shows moments before
kyle rittenhouse opens fire yeah that's
how they phrase it and then instead of
putting the people's name on it they put
person of interest one person of
interest two so you couldn't tell who
was chasing who or who was coming out
from behind a car oh i thought they were
just saying that these were interesting
people oh well they were like oh that's
an interesting fellow well you know what
and i you know how you when you don't
know what to say like that's interesting
that's usually what i say about a
five-time child rapist i'm like that's
interesting and he just got out of the
hospital do you go on yeah do go on do
tell how long you so you're out of jail
oh that makes sense
walking the streets and your icloud is
linked to steven seagal's hard drive wow
that's right
i knew rosenbaum before he was cool
prosecuting kind of traded baseball
cards yes yes
we had custom ones made from tops
so
the prosecuting attorney binger uh these
are some of the arguments that were made
he was trying to admit a cell phone
video with biased commentary uh from a
witness yeah so i want to set this up
here really quick it's been a bad day
for the arguments from the prosecuting
attorneys it's weird uh the prosecutor
tried to justify they were basically
saying okay here's some cell phone
footage and the cell phone footage now
because there's so much footage out
there that shows this case for what it
is has someone providing commentary to
try and you know create a biased slant
right uh and the prosecutor tried to
justify it saying that the judge had
admitted rosenbaum's criminal record
anyway uh bruce schroeder shut down the
prosecutor the judge
when he was
there was an objection like hey hold on
a second just show the footage don't
show commentary right it's like you
don't you don't admit msnbc covering
written house exactly you show the raw
footage you know when the fba can find
it look behind the cinnamon toast crunch
[ __ ] i mean aren't you the f
you're the federal bureau of
investigation investigate it
find out where the tape is
would you record it on beta
tape just got through we loaned it out
oh and americans now the republican
party is dangerous because they're
showing mistrust that are institutions
yeah that's it that's it it must be yeah
it's not the institutions right yeah
themselves yeah yeah it must be uh must
be uh chris christie's fault yeah well
and also give it to the defense when
they ask for it yeah let's not wait
until the last minute to give it to them
it's it's very clear but this judge has
not taken the crap so he uh shut down
the prosecution where they were trying
to present this bias evidence and just i
just just watch it it's great i
understand the objection i the problem
is there are portions of this that that
don't have anything to do with the
defendant that just described the scene
and i'm trying to give the jury that's
what you're saying
it's here saying
i'm not introducing anyone's statements
for the truth of the matter certainly
i'm introducing it for the state of mind
of the defendant as he watches if it's
not for the truth of the matter
it's irrelevant so there's two different
parts of the rule one of them is the
defendant has to have been aware of the
decedent's violent
acts
or
turbulent behavior
in the other one
it's circumstantial evidence
of the victim's violent behavior
at the time of the incident that's what
i admitted it on
now one of these this was on cnn
um jeffrey toobin and uh
another attorney there he was
masturbating
the comment was made that the ruling was
incomprehensible
and i think they obviously are not
familiar with this rule
uh yeah cnn is that what counts for news
no it's just jeff jeff tube and whack at
that so he shows everyone his penis it's
it's fine it's fine and i can't go to a
louis ck show without people judging
right yeah people are gonna people are
gonna boycott me because i go see bill
burr and this guy's there you know
cheese out yo for crying out loud he's a
professional uh choking the chicken yeah
what i'm trying to say here is uh uh
when he was being chased he didn't have
to know his whole background uh he he
could just be afraid of the fact that a
man was chasing you know i mean listen
come on
i don't know why this uh has to be
explained common sense if you look if i
turn around and a guy's yelling [ __ ] you
to me it's a pardon my language and i
hear a gunshot i'd be about as scared as
i would be if i found jeffrey toobin on
my zoom cop yeah i tell them i tell them
right back something like that but i
don't use that sort of language i
usually don't use that sort of language
also i don't uh i don't uh you know i
don't look i'm sorry i know the ladies
here but i don't uh i don't service my
[ __ ] on skype
no i mean i not skype you know
i mean facetime is a bit different you
know yeah i have a i have a subscription
you know when in rome yeah i like it
like a curvy girl but jeffrey tobin you
know i just uh this is why the left
hates this judge by the way oh yeah
because he distrusts the media if
someone has mistrust of the media you're
automatically labeled right wing and by
the way he probably is more of a center
right i would imagine why because he
doesn't like cnn yeah
he doesn't like stupid legal analysts
who don't understand how to read the
next paragraph but he's making he likes
the law yeah yeah it makes it really
easy to see your your kind of team
jersey you know people talk about
polarization in the united states i go
you know what if i see a guy driving in
his car by himself double masked i know
he's my enemy
yeah i know he's probably not going to
be hanging out yeah it's like who are
you going to catch that from yeah yeah i
just know but but i also know that that
guy wants to mandate that i vaccine my
uh 12 week old twins so you know what uh
no
so uh on tuesday when we live streamed
the opening arguments this is what this
is so bad from the prosecution we were
joking about how it almost seemed like
the prosecution
because the process keep in mind the
reason that the left has had to
apologize to all of these outlets all of
the youtube channels all cnn msnbc the
reason they had to apologize and say
okay we were wrong about the fact that a
gun was carried across state lines okay
we were wrong about the fact that uh
written house was chasing rosenbaum
which i know a lot of you here may not
know because you don't watch a lot of
leftist news which i encourage you to do
that's why all references are available
at earthquaker.com they had never seen
the footage which we have shown you all
of it all of it for a long time so the
reason the left had to apologize is
because these facts were brought to
light
by the prosecution
the people who are trying to put kyle
written house away had to say well he
you know he didn't bring a gun across
state lines oh by the way rosenbaum was
chasing him but and when we were
watching it live it was almost like we
had we had stumbled into bizarro world
this is how effective the prosecution
was in defending kyle rittenhouse the
evening begins with large-scale protests
large-scale um right no other way to put
it rioting
what is going on
this guy's the assistant d.a
wow
well where's the worst first string when
you need it
this is how paper thin the case is guys
two out there in the edit bay uh and the
research you guys just send me because
i'm not really using this document since
they screwed it
yeah they've already used all our
materials something you think that i
need to reference that i haven't hit uh
yes for crying out loud
i mean he kind of they didn't make any
arguments kind of took all our points
from these kind of friends
and you know uh
i
i thought maybe the prosecutor maybe
just a slow starter like joe frazier
yeah he'll get it he's got a plan takes
a while to find his rhythm you know uh
i'm getting no now imagine he's black
yes
black
but he's not no it's like this is this
is the prosecutor this isn't like the
prosecutor who starts slow and then
finishes strong he starts the race last
and he ends even further back last
behind last place yes he forgot to tie
his shoes yes before the race that's
what happened slow and steady wins the
race the problem is he just went to
sleep and never woke up oh no just
stayed there just like our tortoise were
just sitting there asleep forever like
that old female turtle in a never-ending
story that was creepy [ __ ] cover your
nose when you sneeze that's gross
here's an argument that the prosecution
tried to present yesterday vaccinate my
turtle that
that kyle's
gun strep
i know you're not going to believe me
i'm going to present it to you here's
the context and you can go watch the
seven hours yourself that kyle
rittenhouse's gun strap should have made
him comfortable with someone grabbing
his gun what there you go and it's
showing you and the other individuals at
the 63rd street car source is that right
yes are you wearing the sling in that
photograph
yes it appears
and is that sling holding that gun
in the front portion of your body
yes does the defendant have his sling on
with his gun being held similar to you
yes
was that sling strong enough to hold the
weight of that gun yes
was that strong was that sling strong
enough so that if someone tried to pull
that gun away the gun would be held to
your body
yes
i have nothing further
can you redirect could we cross rather i
would move exhibit he considers that a
win objection
arrest my case by the way who was that
witness was that adam ruins case law
wow that was an amazing maneuver of no
further questions what uh so he did in
fact grab his gun yeah he went for his
gun
i rest my case yeah he was this thank
you but i wouldn't have lost it right
he's walking past uh he's walking past
the jury boxing
yep
got this one in the back all you have to
do is walk up and go would grabbing a
gun be dangerous oh yeah okay then
what are the guys wearing a strap uh
still dangerous at the very least a dick
move okay
i love how the defense is your witness
yeah yeah the defense is sitting over
there and he's like do you have anything
he's like
i don't want to stop him yeah he's like
he's doing a good job
yeah i gotta tell you they're right in
the house you should have hired this guy
seriously
this guy is uh this guy i don't know if
he's a i don't know if he's a plant if
he's a spy like squalwell banging the
chinese i have no idea i want to disbar
him but i think he's just incompetent
yeah
i mean i don't know what the rule is
because of the you know the law says i
can't fire the handicap and uh
this guy might genuinely be i mean not i
don't mean no offense full-blown
[ __ ] you know is he going to use
that for grounds for appeal i just want
to make sure i understand this correct
prosecution look okay i will speak slow
so you can understand me
do you understand that you just
presented evidence that showed
that someone reached for and was
grabbing kyle rittenhouse's gun in an
aggressive fashion nod your head if you
understand
did you did you ride here on a bicycle
with three wheels i feel like you might
feel wearing a helmet
should you be wearing one of those
leather helmets yeah just at least
something to protect what's left i think
i don't know i might have an old jaffa
from my house hockey
a moral it gets worse oh it does it gets
worse i swear it gets worse it's so
cocky though
like it's just right
do you know what you said yeah
uh and just to be clear uh uh witness i
would like to ask you one last question
was uh mr rosenbaum a serial child
rapist uh yes
no further
he's high-fiving the jury just not even
moving their hands he's like running
through yeah
look of dismay
someone's drinking mcallen 20 here
tonight
not one of them is taking notes
well one of them they just turn around
and says not guilty
i already have it folded and in the head
jersey can i vote now early voting i've
heard is a thing yeah yeah the jury has
already come to a verdict and they've
origamied it yeah they had like oh look
a swan
big middle finger to you ah wow it takes
him forever to unfold
before reading it your honor i ripped
the verdict will kyle rittenhouse be
guilty one two three four
it all just says yes i would kiss you
behind the
swing and y'all i am gonna fight you
behind the bike racks so uh
here's another argument the prosecution
made and this matters it's just it just
shows you how paper paper thin there's
nothing that they have here uh
the guy tries to insinuate that kyle's
friend they're the guy who looks like
college humor is adam
uh being attacked on a roof by rioters
is the same
as
kyle on the ground being attacked and
bludgeoned in the head but here's the
thing even then in trying to draw this
false equivalency of like well you
didn't think there were you need a
deadly force when you were on a roof he
still actually he just like he said
riots he's like why didn't you feel the
need to protect yourself watch what he
says he uses the word why don't you feel
the need to protect yourself when they
were just throwing their little gas
bombs i swear to you watch it
mr richards questions that someone is
throwing some sort of water bottle or
gas bomb up on the roof is that right
very different
when these folks were doing these things
to you and the other members of your
group did you point a gun at anyone no
did you fire at anyone no
why not
because there's no need to i mean
did you feel that by these restraints
throwing rocks at you or throwing a gas
bomb at you that you were in danger
rocks and gas a little bit that means
that pain yes but not danger i knew it
wasn't going to kill me
so you felt like it wasn't enough to use
deadly force correct
no for that
first off a water bottle or a gas bomb
is not a mundane detail michael that's
like a paper planer justin bieber
concert because he won't do an encore
the other is something the penguin uses
to take over gotham
so you uh spilled some wine on your
dates or i'm sorry you threw a grenade
in her mouth
yeah one of the shatter between the
teeth
you know the difference between i don't
know aquafina bottle and a gas bomb yeah
yeah there's a big difference there i
would think you know i know look i don't
want to split hairs on whether it's a
hand grenade or a flash grenade but the
point is you don't want to be a [ __ ]
yeah i mean what are they throwing
fireworks at this guy and like they
don't know what to call them like like
you say roman candle or something and
then when they say objection it was a
gas bomb be like well who could tell but
instead you're sitting there also right
did you know what they were throwing you
know they were throwing pebbles at you
or um uh biological weapons
hey are you were you did you feel
threatened when they threw a dale donut
for a package of ricin i'll tell you
what'll protect against those that true
coat yeah just put that on your
oldsmobile
sometimes i sometimes even put it on my
suede boats
i don't understand so here's another art
so his point is he trying to say you
didn't use deadly force he was on the
roof there's a huge difference between
that yeah and being on the ground with
someone hitting you in the head yeah
kicking you in the head and then someone
else coming up with a gun to shoot you
in the head he's building up their
restraint he just he just said we didn't
feel like that was deadly yeah later on
when you're being chased yeah and the
gun shot actually that's a great point
yeah like so uh
when they were throwing water bottles
and gas bombs and zip guns and chains up
on the roof you didn't feel the need to
uh defend yourself or use deadly force
no we didn't oh
so you issued uh restraint until you
were down on the ground being beaten
within an inch of your life yes sir
christine
now when he pulled a gun on you was it a
sandwich
i don't it was dark
could it have been a foot lock yeah yeah
uh no it was an ar-15 how could you tell
because i know the model it's a daniel
defense tonight oh
where big man you are could have been a
water bottle it could have been a water
bottle i don't know they get clever with
those new water bottles you ever see
that uh life water has a squeeze tube or
you have to open the cap
you don't want that in your eye or maybe
you do i don't know i don't know you
know you could make some anthrax in
there who's to tell so here's
here's his next argument
hand to god
all references are available
hand real footage
you're not going to believe what i'm
about to say
sketch
no
he argues that rosenbaum you know you
see in that footage that he ducks behind
the car yeah and puts something over his
face right so the second he sees kyle
rittenhouse right he hides kyle right
now he's coming covers something over
his face before him and his buddy you
know his guy in coordination shoots the
gun and he yells [ __ ] you pardon my
language but i want to quote this
accurate right yeah uh kyle rittenhouse
he's arguing that the reason he went and
decided to lawrence of arabia his face
was uh
because he was distressed from covid
i think you indicated that his face was
obscured by the shirt
is that right yes
were you wearing a mask that night yes
yeah you could tell by my voice i was
muffled the entire night yeah and this
was in august of 2020 when there was a
lot of code going around correct yeah is
it fair to say that a lot of people that
night had face coverings
yes
yeah by the way uh the prosecution also
blamed the emotional stress of covid for
this
look that's what it's a symptom yep you
must have had one of those breakthrough
cases one of those
very distressed
yeah that would make sense prosecuting
dummy if he wasn't seen all night yeah
repeatedly yelling the n-word without a
face covering which he should have
because he's really white
[Laughter]
yeah it would have at least hidden the
n-word yeah where you could go i didn't
say it did you say that no no it's
muffled you couldn't hear i mean throw
your voice a little bit like senior one
says like hey don't use that don't you
say that word these are good people so
right
walter yeah peanuts
[Laughter]
oh my gosh well no steven he got a phone
update from the cdc that said kovid was
dangerous at that time yeah okay the
arguments yeah that's there oh that's
good how did he have a phone
fresh out of uh the clink oh he sorry
the mental health he stole it from some
kid
oh oh that's true
yeah it only called two people right
unfortunately 9-1-1 and the parents were
not accessible
oh my god sorry they just made me laugh
because they weren't the whole city was
on fire that guy could have gotten away
with worse
could have gotten away with a lot more
so thank god kyle renton house was there
well thank god he was there but we would
never ever want to want someone to be
hurt no no no no no we would never want
to see someone uh you know someone uh
commit the horrible act of self-defense
never we would we would we would rather
see this is my question honestly to the
left before i go on to the horrible
arguments what
what would you rather see
at that point
covered now be bludgeoned to death with
a skateboard genuinely left us out there
and say well he shouldn't have been
there okay but he's there it's like a
kid it's like oh she shouldn't have run
that mini skirt right kid shouldn't be
at a party he's underage drinking it's
very similar right right misdemeanor
okay shouldn't have been there not even
a felony a weapon my question to you is
once you see him on the ground stomp
kicked hit in the head with a skateboard
and someone running up with a gun
what would you what would you rather
happen
what would make you satisfied
in uh what would have you believe that
cal written house is not a white
supremacist
would it have to be his brains on the
concrete i genuinely i'm trying to see
the other side of the argument here he's
running
serial pedophile who's aggressive who's
committed acts of violence felonies that
night already on camera running after
him
yelling [ __ ] you get him the second cal
written house turns running this guy has
a chain is reaching for his gun gunshots
go off in the air he turns around to see
this ginger pedophile that is ball
retractingly scary what
what what is it does he wait for the
pedophile to
to brain him and
to to rape him because he's underage
that's something this guy does my point
is what would what would satisfy you
genuinely to believe that coloring house
is not some white supremacist he didn't
kill any black people didn't shoot any
black people
he was yelling friendly friendly
friendly he was providing medical care
to people of any political persuasion
i i don't know i wouldn't care no it
doesn't matter because they wanted to
fit the agenda of exactly what they're
trying to push they want a scalp well
this is what they want they want to
blame him you're calling a guy a white
supremacist for shooting a white
pedophile yes does that make sense to
anybody at all uh well i think cnn
they're like sounds good to me yeah no
that's that's uh that's fair tubin said
it yeah so it must be true i haven't
said it but i couldn't hear him over the
sound of one hand clapping
he seemed real thrilled about it though
yeah very excited i was asking him at
first what's it what's the faucet on no
it's his [ __ ] boy i tell you though when
he stopped clapping he got depressed oh
boy
i tell you it's the just knocked the
wind right out of him he just said i'm a
monster and then it shut off
am i speaking of monsters what's wrong
with me especially
speaking of monsters
this is the prosecution smoking gun here
like they really were smug about this
doesn't like their the glove that
doesn't fit oh boy
[Applause]
they were trying to say right that kyle
was chasing rosenbaum down remember
during the original stream they said
they had fbi footage that showed
cabernet was chasing rosenbaum
the prosecution's
own witness
said no and refuted this here you go
would you agree with me mr washington
that as you pass by
the defendant and joseph rosenbaum
heading south on sheridan road
that the
sequence of individuals is mr rosenbaum
is further south
ahead of the defendant mr rittenhouse
correct yes and
you were asked by
attorney binger
in terms of
the direction that people are heading
that mr
rosenbaum is further south
than mr rittenhouse in that picture
right yes okay you'd agree on that video
it doesn't appear that mr rittenhouse is
chasing mr rosenbaum does it
no it doesn't
it appears they like multiple other
people are simply walking
south
agreed yes
wow
and the prosecutor's not even smart
enough to go [ __ ] he's going like well
that's i told you i had an ace in the
hole yeah
getting bad witness
who's the assistant next to him that big
dude who's just like writing stuff down
like we're not going to win this
this is hopeless this is life right now
it's a t-ball schedule
i'm getting fired after this i better
get that dental work done if he were
defending chris pringle partner after
that
so if you were defending kris kringle
someone would open out the windows like
hey horrible news everybody santa's
getting executed
this is great it's a bag of no letters
to santa yes i'm just emptying out
nothing
i just
okay you guys could cut is it me look i
i want to know if i have a blind spot
now keep in mind
i have watched the arguments from the
left on the cow right now saying i just
will say it's just lies i'm like well
they say kylo renos was chasing why they
say that cal written house uh brought a
firearm across state lines well that's
just a lie they say that no one that he
was the one who fired the first shot
that's just a lie i've watched all of
the raw footage not the one not the raw
footage that the fbi has destroyed of
course yeah yeah i just don't
i just don't see it you comment below
let me know what what you think is even
the possibility
of a jury coming back saying guilty
maybe on the firearm charge maybe on the
firearm charge but what kind of
responsibility does the prosecution have
to also not lie
he basically
sorry didn't basically he went out and
said that ridden house was chasing
rosenblum in his opening statement and
then tried to reassert it there when the
video clearly shows that's not what
happened he's a lawyer no no no no that
doesn't give him an excuse to actually
don't bring your anti-semitic [ __ ] in
here quarter black yes come on it's not
about that listen go watch the right hey
yourself that's what they do admonish
yourself i will not i have control
yes
he's not on the stand his job is to lie
ah we have ways you don't know you
actually tell him you go i killed this
dude and they go what we're going to try
to prove he didn't
that's his job
his job is to lie no it's
yes it is no it's to present evidence in
a way how many times have you hired a
lawyer to get off
i have
and every time i'm like here's what we
gotta do i've never gotta act like i was
sober and we both know i wasn't
like
we gotta lie i'm uh i'm real guilty
that's why i'm calling you
isn't that your job yeah i don't want to
call it an honest lawyer that's why they
made the movie liar liar because he
couldn't lie and he lost all his cases
it's also why they made devil's advocate
yeah oh yeah yeah exactly
it's just having sex with the devil or
charlie's there and i don't remember but
canner reeves gets burned alive
no
he's like that's just sister dreams
that's what it was right wasn't it yeah
oh that's your sister you're disgusting
having sex with your sister let me get
the video tape gotta watch he wanted it
he's like yay god says look but don't
touch yeah that's right
that's right but don't lie through it
i've watched for those who don't
remember this there's a movie a film was
it would you say mid 90s late 90s like
uh which movie nine double advocate 97.
it was 99 98.
people out there
for all you people who say okay boomers
we're millennials there is a film
uh called devil's advocate with kenner
reeves al pacino and charlie starring i
think right yes yeah and it was not
market spoiler alert it was never
marketed as though the devil actually
has sex with his sister uh you just
thought like devil's advocate like
always a really dishonest yeah really
dishonest lawyer you know i mean like
what to what let you know to what
lengths will a lawyer go to deserve and
then you're like oh this is actually
about someone who's the devil who's
having sex with uh family members and uh
this is really weird and it wasn't
marketed that way at all no the twist is
the fact that he is the devil and the
movie's called the devil's edge yes also
another great twist in that movie
jeffrey jones you might know him as the
principal from ferris bueller's day off
who is a pedo is a pedo in that movie so
he gets chased down and attacked by
demons you gotta think when he was
watching that he's like boy
i hope that doesn't happen hit a little
close to home
in three more years people are gonna
realize how real this is why couldn't he
have been in kenosha i know
yeah he was like a pete townsend sort of
where he's like i was researching a
project on
karate circumcision
him and the dad from seventh heaven uh
yeah that guy too really yeah
we can't do the alec ball in seven plus
one we don't have time i think should we
should we do that or should we do the
professor uh
professor penis waiting in the wings
what do we think they're talking about
um let's do it both these fans love us
what do we think i mean i can talk about
the the female thing next week but i
know that we we titled it we kind of
titled around it but we did hit a whole
bunch of other stuff so what seven plus
one is that i think the seven plus one
is pretty uh it's timely can we okay
people send us some chats really quickly
we have a whole thing about feminism
ruining everything for women we'll do it
next and then we have seven plus one
what do you think they're quarter black
and don't bring your fair economy okay
don't
i think we should do both oh he wants to
show hours we should do an hour and a
half show on youtube
dare you all right fine look it's gonna
be an hour and a half show on youtube
and rumble and then we're gonna go late
we're gonna go late because we're still
doing another 45 minutes on mug club
look look i'm only getting thursday if
you guys smash that like button right
now on youtube do it smash the like
button we're watching you know what
we're gonna monitor unless there's
unless there is exactly eight thousand
likes before right now it is 1108 before
12 000 right now so no no no i'm saying
a different from here
by 11 20 then i'm just going to cut the
feed short we're just gonna we're just
gonna stop yeah we'll save the plus one
because they didn't do it because they
didn't do it you're only gonna get seven
you're not even gonna know you're not
even gonna get the plus one there's
always supposed to be one in the chamber
always don't forget about it
my point is you don't deserve this
wait what no i'm kidding that's one
thing too i will say i don't know if
it's going down a rabbit trail too much
but people people like when we started
you know mug club and we do appreciate
you joining up live with credit.com we
actually do full segments and a full
extra show stuff we can never talk about
on youtube you should see what dave says
the issue here is uh we never pulled
away free content a lot of people do
free content and then they say hey uh
now it's no longer free you have to pay
we only did once a week a free show yeah
up to five thousand already likes five
thousand more five thousand up so all
right there we go some of you are paying
me an hour and a half yeah in like a
minute we have a very active audience we
do and we didn't we never wanted to
screw you guys we had one free show a
week and since we started premium
content you now get four free shows away
what 20 000 likes
that was fast you guys are crazy hold on
a second guys hold on a second i mean
25. now a second
i'm going to pull a fouchy 20 000 more
likes
20 000. hey come on twenty thousand more
likes you wanna have thanksgiving twenty
one now you don't even have to have the
likes
because likes are rolling in thirty
thousand likes we were five thousand i
threw the pitch
i'd like
yeah we were a little too generous with
the time next time we'll be like in the
next four minutes yeah yeah yeah
i think i would have got it anyways we
had a whole shelf written for monday we
got eight thousand likes and nine yeah
crazy wow why aren't you
it's still going on by the way that's
how quickly joe biden gets dislikes
that's true yeah that's true so like ah
i swallowed wrong just
you can watch it like ed rooney had a
foul computer attendance day changes
i just swallowed one race
come on chris all right sad to find out
the real reason he's breaking into
ferris's house
no don't take that as license dave to go
i didn't say nothing i was just saying
the hodge
tonight watch the devil's advocate with
uh your spouse or significant other or
yeah yeah whatever
yeah you can really watch al pacino at
its best
we're at 26 000. i like it oh yeah baby
demons asses they're great big
they go red asses big old red ashes with
hearts
can you take it down maybe i don't know
from a 10 to a 1. i like moderately
large red ashes all right let's just use
this move on yeah that's the clipper
when did he forget how to act i don't
know the subtlety of mike corleone you
need your pen all right so i'll get my
pen once the intro comes up so uh the
husband of helena hutchins uh the person
who was shot on the alec baldwin hired a
lawyer uh brian pernich she's a personal
injury lawyer from los angeles
he represented the mother of uh sorry
the mother and children of michael
jackson and so this is going to be a
tough legal battle for alec baldwin and
so that brings us to this week's seven
plus one
[Music]
you'll forgot
the chamber
they always forget the whole every time
you can't forget the one in the chamber
alex forget one in the chamber come on
all right dangerous and this week it is
seven plus one alec baldwin defenses
oh yeah excuses
the top seven plus one alec baldwin
excuses uh as to what really happened
why he shot number seven i saw the
cameras and thought they were paparazzi
well that oh well no well that makes
sense gunshots are a little number six
seven plus one alec baldwin excuses dave
you take number six there it wasn't me
it was my brother's wife from wilson
phillips that was kinda okay looking
yeah well that just seems like a
backhanded
insult number five saying i wouldn't
pork the pork no
number five alec baldwin excuses
i could have sworn she was my daughter
let you know just how i feel about what
a rude little pig you really are well
that shows you everything you need to
know number four excuses from alec
baldwin the instructions were in spanish
and i had my wife translate
that [ __ ] don't know spanish let's uh
let's uh let's do uh number three alec
baldwin excuses dave
i i had just rewatched my movie drunk
parents and felt someone had to die
had to die
agent was not available number two alec
paul excuses uh that's not a loaded
unchecked weapon in my pants i'm just
happy to see you
that just seems more like a confession
really yeah it's weird right doesn't
seem like it seems like that's not going
to be a defense no which is a a reason
that's like the prosecution in
rittenhouse it really is is he having
the same lawyer that's what it seems
because if so he's going to get somehow
three charges of murder at
the church
and it'll be like looking like oh also
uh mr baldwin the jury's decided to
charge you in the death of brandon lee
so i don't know how that happened but uh
wow we're just uh really going back in
time here but i'll allow it
all right number one the top excuse alec
baldwin has given for the mishap onset
of rust dave
earlier that day the broad eye shot took
my parking spot oh come on now that's
not a reason alex
you're better than that and of course
the plus one you would have just hit her
yes he would have just hit her the plus
one uh or if he was you know caitlyn
jenner would have run her over uh plus
one uh i was still upset about being
portrayed uh as the head of the film
actors guild until america yeah
that
is the [ __ ] way
one day you all look at the world us
actors created and say
wow
good going [ __ ]
yeah i could see how that could be a
little uh a little unnerving for alec
baldwin all right that's been this week
seven plus one
[Music]
you forgot
the chamber
okay so
he did yeah he certainly did well
somebody did on this one yes yeah well
he is the produce look you can also have
empathy for the fact that it was you
know an accident and he didn't tend to
murder somebody
it's sad but there's also some
culpability somewhere and if you're the
producer and you are always supposed to
check your weapon yeah yeah well we are
at still zero instances here in louder
with crowder studios even after using
guns several times over the years yep
still zero incident nobody's this is a
loaded gun with one in the chamber this
is what's so funny you know someone
knows nothing about guns
you have your guns loaded no i keep it
in a lot lock box in the other area of
the house so i can run around what yes
of course it's loaded and ready why
would i have it so i could wish i had a
gun when a burglar comes through the
window but if your job is to check guns
on a film set what were you doing yeah
well it's like driving home you're like
did i leave the oven on yeah something
today yeah he's like hey you know what i
was thinking today instead of checking
the guns i'd uh load them yeah um and
just leave them about on the set yeah
you know just see what happens it's uh
all the greats leave their mark really
rolling the dice there aren't you uh
when you take this gun
sometimes they can shoot off well it's
very rare yeah very right just make sure
you point them directly at two people
yeah and just her defense she was
distracted doing a tick-tock and don't
let the screams break your concentration
it's important that you stay in
character it's very important that you
stay in character here on rest
you think he called his daughter right
away he's like oh it's all your fault
someone knew it you pig like a sweaty
pig i told you i told you that you were
supposed to load it with planks i don't
care if you're 11 or 12. i'm i'm 21.
i don't like your mother
she used to be hot she's not hot anymore
not since since eight miles she's
disgusting you pig i'm gonna take this
out on you
all right so this is something else i
really want to talk about
sorry i really wanted to talk about this
today and i know that this is something
uh keep an open mind
because i understand that not all women
are feminists and not all feminists are
women so
um
however there has been a lot of there's
there's been a lot of sort of
reshuffling amongst uh female ranks and
i don't just mean with
women female conservatives women female
female i'll just go with female who
cares yeah uh see what that they used to
be interchangeable until like last may
so
uh we do need to talk about a couple of
things all of the problems that women
are dealing with right now
you they're listening right now and you
can tell me if these are problems that
you commonly deal with these are the
most common problems cited by women
are in have been entirely created by the
leftist feminist movement and
unfortunately women allowing them to
spread their roots to get their
tentacles in too deep that's why we find
ourselves at a point right now where a
lot of women are are panicking going all
right okay you show us where the
gubernatorial race is going
they're doing this with their kids oh my
gosh what's happening there are no men
out there there's something now that's
been going on there was an op-ed about
golden penis syndrome and i'll just
explain it to you really quickly
basically in a lot of areas particularly
on college campuses uh the women
outnumber the men right now in the
dating pool yeah so they outnumber the
men depending which ratio you use three
to one or three to two and they're
saying there aren't enough men and now
they're just playing the field and they
just they think that they have a golden
penis this is what the it's called
golden penis syndrome the great name and
i don't want to get too nerdy about it
so actually to explain this uh a
professor uh in in peanut sciences uh
penis and penis related sciences
professor penis is going to explain this
for us
[Music]
all right professor penis i need you to
take that microphone there uh yeah we're
trying out a new
yeah a new set up sound professor
professor penis okay can you just give
me let me get my pointer out yeah okay
uh can you explain to us exactly for
people who don't know too this is sort
of a so so sociological i guess at this
point isn't it properly yes
physical as well yeah okay so explain to
us what golden penis syndrome is okay so
complicated name uh the correlation of
female to male ratio to the metallic
quality of male phallus okay it's
complicated but it is very simple so
this will be easy one to understand okay
we've got uh down here on the x-axis the
ratio of females to males well yeah
that's the problem starting at one to
one okay that'll be our baseline and
then going to you know any uh
x integer okay sure number integer all
the way up
y-axis we got the goldenness of the
penis the level of metallic no see i
think
professor penis i i think um goes like
this i don't see plateau i don't think
that uh golden penis syndrome is
actually
like a physical like golden penis right
uh i mean i'm i'm not a
geologist or a materials scientist so i
kind of stick with i get the numbers and
i kind of do the more academic you know
philosophical questions okay so uh all
right
that being said we we i mean we did open
submissions to to like send gold from
people actually this is important right
yeah you know you're not alone yeah my
university put out a call for for people
suffering from golden penis syndrome
exactly people who are uh dealing with
this disease yeah okay and explain what
kind of what that uh what what that
might look like see what my interns have
sent me here
all right on our list we got uh okay we
got a few
zac efron yeah movie star uh 14 carats
what do you mean what does that mean 14k
of
penis
of gold his penis is 14k gold so that's
equality wow yeah this is these are the
measures you can
self-submitted will like appraise these
yeah we'll verify these yeah of course
it needs to be authentic
okay hurry up
uh we also have see another oh tom brady
football yeah talking about football
yeah
tom brady had uh
22 carats 22 karat penis tom brady i
don't think that this is exactly but you
know what just for good measure those
are two successful people zach they are
yeah yeah tom brady let's
act as though you have this correct uh
you know for contra
bruce springsteen springs c in there uh
we put an s
i mean yo okay we do have them actually
uh looks like pyrite
uh that's uh fool's gold okay
everybody that's been that's been
enlightening okay
[Music]
all right well that was just a horrible
waste oh my gosh
i mean i get what he's saying though
yeah
i don't doubt exactly zac efron's
probably got a fortune character yeah he
probably does 14. it's kind of low until
he's well yeah he's probably more yeah
but i mean he's not enough
with the rock then it shrinks to uh
eight carat ah yes or a ten carat maybe
an eight
yeah okay so this got me thinking here
um that's not true dave yeah it is you
won't see it all right let me get to a
few points here the the major gripes
that you're seeing from look this is
something i want to talk about
uh
a lot of
the issues that women are upset about
right now they're legitimate grievances
okay and i'm talking about the
grievances that affect your life the
most not about abortion up until
including birth and keep in mind by the
way uh the racist white women write the
hashtag they voted out governor
blackface who believed in you know
northam uh who believed in abortion up
until including birth and they voted in
was it lieutenant uh lieutenant governor
i don't think he was the lieutenant
governor what's the name of the black
lady who was a foreign governor yeah
he's undergoing the governor now yeah so
i don't know i don't understand the
rules with white supremacy but i'm not
sure whatever either
it's anyone who disagrees with you oh i
understand it's not actually about race
okay the former marine black lieutenant
governor now who's yeah the blackface i
guess of white supremacy in virginia now
because those are popping up second
generation immigrant okay yeah so get it
i get it i don't get it i'll talk about
it after you guys can clarify for me so
but i i don't want to talk about just
those issues which are sort of existing
this you know i guess sort of
nebulous kind of like oh women's rights
no the issues that are facing women this
is the golden penis syndrome okay and
this is a problem where women are saying
there aren't enough men available
also in new york ironically in this com
it's exacerbated by a significant gay
population in new york
[Laughter]
where would that stem from that i don't
think the sexual liberation from the
from the feminist movement would have
anything to do with that so
every issue that you complain about
women
legitimately and i am empathetic towards
you i have a white woman
wife just to be clear hashtag white
woman i have a wife who's a stay-at-home
mom now and she used to be a
professional
so uh i have some experience with this
living with a woman and and what it is
that she has valued and where she has
found herself uh happier
here's the issue
women if you look back at what women
wanted in the 1940s 1950s 1960s and
you'll try and say oh
no voting oh abusing women no these
things were never these things abusing
your wife was never something that was
so societally accepted that's not
patriarchy patriarchy the
patriarchy was they were the ones who
voted for women to have a right to vote
most women didn't want the right to vote
because of the responsibilities that it
came with i'm not talking about that
what i'm talking about is what women
wanted out of life in the 1950s 1940s
and specifically what they wanted out of
men has changed
decade to decade so dramatically whereas
what men want from women
is still the exact same
and that's why women are many of you are
finding yourself in a scenario
where you're unhappy and you realize
that the wool's been pulled over your
eyes where now they control your kids
and hormone blockers and they're
teaching them critical race theory and
they're giving them books with kids and
strap-ons at the virginia school public
library and all of a sudden you've been
taken for granted because something
something something uh vulva right so
let's go through some of the primary
gripes that i hear women often
complaining about today and this is now
from the feminist movement
that have been created a self-fulfilling
prophecy one okay here you go that women
are being sexually objectified you hear
this a lot this is a problem now right
and you have the error of me too and
again men need to clean house with me
too
right it's men who need to kick the ass
of rapists hey by the way do you want to
know what hap see how rapists and child
molesters do in prison yeah even violent
male criminals aren't huge fans just to
be clear
there's a reason weinstein kept it to
himself outside of you know matt damon
well i think weinstein's gonna have no
issue in the rape department no no no no
no it'll be a rape cornucopia yes they
may beat him daily though yeah yeah just
because look at he's a slob he's
absolutely disgusting he's just tough to
look at so women are sexually
objectified well look i would agree with
that i think that's a problem that we
have now that we certainly didn't have
back uh in the 1940s 50 let's say 50 for
the sake of argument here because a lot
of times they say oh maga means go back
to the 1950s which is racism and sexism
but now they're going oh we can't find a
man on college okay on college campus
all right
feminists were the feminists the
feminist movement okay and when i am
saying this i'm talking about the
feminist leftist movement and
unfortunately because women value
empathy over
conflict and resolution in many ways you
know this if you're married they've
allowed feminists to run wild so i'm not
saying all women but i am saying this is
a problem that has been created
exclusively
in the female community uh
feminism lauded the sexual liberation
movement
this this coincided with birth control
right they said hey free sex right free
sex free love that was the idea and
guess what you let men off the hook this
didn't come from men
now men have always wanted to have sex
with as many women as they could because
that's the way that they're biologically
hardwired right for example look at gay
couples promiscuity is almost
non-existent why because everyone just
says uh yes all the time
all the time it was women who civilized
men and said no you got to put a ring on
it right that was how it used to work a
man used to have to court romance a
woman and then get married and they
would be engaged in a sexually
monogamous relationship i feel like
there was a guy like behind the curtain
pulling the strains like you want to
have sex with everyone yeah exactly like
guys are like oh no please don't do that
this is not the penis you're looking for
yeah seriously it's like the topless
thing like ah free the nipple to to piss
off matt it's like this like the women's
sexual liberation i bet you donald trump
was back like oh no
that free sex stop gross
the first like motion picture to ever
come at was like it was like a train you
know they finally filmed something and
the second one i believe was a naked
woman on a tire swing i'm not even
kidding yeah it's like that's how
quickly you just go into perversion with
any invention that we've ever had yeah
it's like the internet we're like hey
this is an amazing way we can
communicate with and masturbate yes yeah
well is that a tire swing well that
would look nice out in the old boot
radley's front yard yeah
i put my snatch on it is that let's make
porn free
i was gonna say to be fair that first
movie it was called train coming into a
station was it really yeah yeah stop it
there you go there's a little symbolism
there all right here's another second
one was part two the issue is the stop
gap was removed from carnal sexuality
and now a lot of women are upset that
and rightfully so i agree with you yeah
that a lot of men are pl this is what's
happening the golden penis syndrome
they're playing the field because they
have more options and an underlying
theme here that you will understand that
women have
throughout the decades tried to increase
their value in the romance and in in the
dating marketplace in ways that they see
men add value
but it doesn't add value to a man what
do i mean women have said well i'm a
professional career woman well men don't
care women say well i make a good income
men don't care well i have a college
degree men don't care you value that in
a man the man still values the same
things in general when polled kindness
being attractive
nurturing loyal these are things are not
going men don't say oh
does she make a good income
women
see that as valuable because that's the
role of protector and provider whether
you want to admit it or not and so
you've tried to increase your value
through being more like a man it's just
like having female action stars like how
about you just have that's why gambit uh
queen's gambit was great you're the best
female chess player fantastic there's no
reason that can't happen why because
women can be just as good at chess
women cannot
you can't beat someone's ass with a high
heel you're gonna get your ass kicked
okay charlize
so if you try to empower women by
telling them to be more like men here
you go now men aren't all that
interested and that brings me to another
point we hear this a lot that men will
not commit right this is a complaint
among them and you know what
it's actually true yeah we saw it in
some of the chat questions i've been
dating somebody for four or five years
and i'm like wait what that shouldn't
happen and this is true men are not
willing to commit why again this goes
back to point number one the sexual
revolution right and marriage just isn't
also seen as a winning proposition this
is something that's important a lot of
people don't understand too it's
increasing expectations in marriage
of men where men used to be the provider
men used to be the protector and women
would be at home with the children and
now it's also you share all the
household duties also your mr mom at
home and also if i leave you for any
reason i'm going to take half this is a
part of the feminist revolution and so
men say well you know what that's a risk
that i don't really want to take women
these laws were changed
by women
these these these ideas were championed
by women
men never wanted it to be clear just
like they don't want a woman today who's
35 with a gender studies degree in
student student debt to be the mother of
their children
turn back now
here's another one that you see a lot of
women now too when they look at the
dating pool you can read this in the
golden penis syndrome men don't make
enough money right oh it's really tough
i can't find a man who who makes enough
money well look okay why do you think
that is when feminism pushed the idea
and not only pushed the idea denigrated
the idea of single-income households or
stay-at-home mom they pushed the idea of
a dual income household yeah it was
considered to feminists less respectable
to the point where a lot of women
decided i'm going to find look
find take pride in your job absolutely
but take pride in being a mother too
take pride in being a wife too do you
not want your husband to take pride in
being a good husband being a faithful
husband being a loving husband
the qualities that you admire in a man
take pride in being a wife and a mother
not just a career you can take pride in
either or but generally speaking not
both you can't have it all and so when
you change this
uh and women just to be clear
what they're seeing now is a lot of men
sort of going into the job pool
uh as women used to so before the 1960s
women muslim buddies yes yes
women used to you know that a lot of
them were teachers when they say women
weren't allowed in the workforce no
women were teachers women made up the
majority of nurses things like
assistants secretaries now why not
because they weren't qualified not
because men were trying to hold them
back and i'm sure there's some of that
but a big reason was women back then
valued flexibility over say pay being a
ceo traveling why because that would
take them away from their kids and at
this point society and humanity
recognize that women are generally
happier when they're
close with their children can spend time
with their children as women's share of
household duties has gone as
consistently gone down so is their
happiness i am not saying that [ __ ]
should be happier if you were cleaning
the floor what i am saying is that as
women have started to make more money as
women have been allowed at record rates
in the stem fields whether qualified or
not because many women don't want to
enter into these fields they are
becoming less happy because they are
realizing that it's not as fulfilling as
the lie that feminists sold you
what is fulfilling
sings the first smile on your children's
face
having a warm house at home taking pride
you can still work i'm not saying you
can't but i'm saying that as women have
increasingly placed a premium on work
they're becoming less happy it would be
just like if let's take an extreme
example if all men today were
stay-at-home dads they didn't go to work
guarantee you male suicide would be
higher guarantee you depression will be
higher because you know what that's not
what we were designed to do
and it would be a monumental shift yeah
exactly and i hate the lie that is being
sold by the left right now that women
you shouldn't value
giving birth you shouldn't value having
a child you shouldn't value right like
the most my wife and i sat down you know
my wife is a badass she's incredibly
intelligent she can do whatever she
wants to do and she's got a really great
job
we've sat down and said the most
important thing that we will ever do is
raise our children well 30 40 50 years
ago we gave up on that and we are
reaping what we have sown because now
you're saying government raise our kids
or daycare and i understand situations
arise where you have to go to daycare
because mom and dad have to work i'm not
talking about that i'm talking about
people not valuing raisins well that
also by the way comes from people who
try and blame the government society it
also comes from increasing expectations
with placing a value on material goods
and working a job there are still plenty
of families who live in rural areas who
have single income households you find
these people at church
just to be clear
right but this is this the problem now
is more men because of the idea of dual
income households so i don't need to
become a ceo i don't need to worry about
a promotion i don't want to worry about
a pension you know i'll just look for
more flexibility
because they can live men now on a lower
middle income salary alone single and
live like a king
or this is a challenge too is what they
they get married you have dual income
and at that point they work all day come
home work all night if they have
children because they're also the mother
you split this 50 50 you're splitting
work 50 50.
it's just not a winning proposition for
a lot of men and um a lot of them choose
to remain single that's the thing guys
are going ah you know what
i live better
by myself if it's going to be a joint
income you know what i'll just keep my
income and uh live with three roommates
rather than be rather than have to
commit and have her take half if i run
that risk we might say i thought you got
to say something i was i forgot what
okay oh no i was saying now they also
have apps
right yeah sex apps i don't mean to
sound like uh i don't mean to date
myself
but what i'm trying to say well i guess
never mind but what i'm trying to say is
uh yeah i've never used a dating app
because i i haven't been single when i
was popular but it is amazing you can
just like throw people's faces away like
they're garbage yeah yeah like the one
you want to bang right yeah that seems
that seems uh bad yeah i'm sorry dave
dave let me you're saying
that objectifying women and just picking
the one that you would like to bang is a
bad thing correct okay i just wanted to
be clear it seems it is a bad thing
counter-intuitive to a feminist movement
it does seem counter-intuitive oh by the
way thanks feminists for all the porn
because now they're like no no no no you
said body positivity right it was about
uh it was art something like that
empowerment thank you
now you are less desirable
to a lot of men
why is ron jeremy in jail isn't he the
king of body positivity yes but also not
even that now that you have gone out and
said oh this free your body let the
women this is empowering to you now you
have the potential of ending up in a
relationship with a man who has seen the
very very best i'm sorry porn is
absolutely horrific but airbrushing and
just cutting scenes together you've seen
what the best of sex could possibly be
which is completely unattainable it's
not real and now they go into a
relationship where it underperforms and
all of a sudden the thing that was meant
to bring you guys together in a way that
nothing else could is a disappointment
yeah but horrific so i mean i mean
yeah cheryl's the one who started
throwing horrific around listen porn is
written but it is not my story thank god
it's terrific i heard you say nobody
took a girl on a first date and was like
listen i just want to get to the movies
use your feet on me
just put on the pop put on this strap
i read it in a chill i read i read it at
the school library oh yeah that's what
the best part of that children's book is
the kid going uh i don't this isn't how
i expected it let's do something else
yeah what are you going to go back to
riding bikes
yeah you think after servicing your
transgender sister with a strap-on that
you can go back to having fun on your
fixie yeah just time to go back and play
a little nintendo that's this is all one
big advertisement for like ah this is
boring pow pow power wheels
now you're sucking for real
all right here's another complaint that
you see from women and it's sort of it's
sort of a
and by the way women out there i would
love to hear your comments but these are
the we get these chat feedbacks all the
time and you do and you're seeing
liberals writing about these from
a different perspective they just want
to come up with a different solution
which is more emasculation so men are
lazy slobs you see this argument a lot
uh guess what that's absolutely true in
a lot of ways
men in the 40s sorry boys teenagers were
storming the beaches of normandy you
look at the 1930s look at the 1940s look
at the greatest generation you look what
they were doing and if they weren't
doing that if there hadn't been a war
they'd be working in the factory lines
or they'd be starting a business anyway
are they out there
learning a trade
even after they had gone to college if
they were so lucky to have gone to
university nowadays you're more likely
to run into a 30 something year old sort
of seth rogen archetype living with a
bunch of roommates in apartments it's an
actual syndrome called second
adolescence
this is what we have right now
and let's ask why why did we go from
storming the beaches
and i'm not just talking about the draft
why did we go from the kinds of men and
even lower testosterone levels by the
way that's an act that's a fact
historically right now men have lower
testosterone levels than their than
their grandfather why did we why do we
make that transition um
could it be because
feminists and women by and large and
this is also not just feminists you see
this with moms and boys a lot
and i know you don't mean to do it
but women naturally recoil at what a boy
actually is
it's very foreign to them sometimes how
physical how violent how aggressive they
are how assert guess what these are also
the same characteristics that make men
leaders in times of war
that make men great ceos of companies
all the things that you portray is toxic
masculinity i'm not talking about
beating women
i'm not talking about objectifying women
i'm talking about someone being
assertive in a leadership role with
respect and admiration which is what men
have wanted it's what they've always
wanted it's what would make them most
happy today and instead you've demonized
it and now ask where all the real men
have gone to
it's a really stark contrast and you can
see it
biochemically in hormone levels yeah and
it's not just because of bpa in the
plastic
and you don't care about that because
you just think that's a xenoestrogen but
you want to inject boys with estrogen
anyway so shut up yeah well and on top
of that you've also told men that if you
hit i remember the gillette commercial
where a guy saw a pretty girl walking by
and he was about to go and try to talk
to her and his body was like no no no no
bro and i'm like so now you've even told
us like we can't even we can't even try
to get to know you we can't even try to
say hi my name's gerald you know like
hey what are you i've seen you walking
here before or anything like that like
guy wasn't making cat calls let me give
you an exact example okay what i'm
talking about me too movement though not
catcher but the metoo movement did that
it confused dating with rape absolutely
absolutely why do you think guys are
afraid to date a lot of the time it's
not even the fault of in my opinion
women in the workplace i think it's this
entire movement that made men actually
that's a huge complaint
and i
he makes it like well you know what i'm
not i'm not in a rush well you can
retroactively be raped because you were
regretted having consensual sex with
someone you know these are two things
i'm saying women placing priority on a
premium on the workplace and really sort
of a belittling the job of motherhood is
what has
caused women to be less happy today
statistically more rates of depression
and what i'm talking about separate the
separate issue though is true the reason
men have also left the dating pool there
are two separate issues but you're
absolutely right and you know what this
is something else to to keep in mind
i'll give you an exact story okay
violence is not immoral
violence is amoral just like money
money can be used to i can go give that
to a starving child i can go give it to
my church or i can go and buy crack
one time during the war i visited a
prostitute one time yeah and my wife my
life's been a living hell ever since and
by prostitute i mean nine but it was all
at once so they were all in paris
so
my i have a relative i won't say this
person's name
lives in new york
and when he's called him when you say i
do need it no it's not shout out joe
okay let me finish the story because
this is important women are going to go
well we don't want men were walking
around smacking women no i'm not saying
that you don't what you do want though
is a man who's going to protect you and
respect and honor you and i will say
this is a relative of mine who's a
christian
and was on a subway in new york and this
man and he did happen to be of uh
african-american origin i don't know it
could have been from barbados that's an
entirely racist term black
he uh was
harassing
somebody on the subway and my
this man's wife i almost
this man's wife my relative was just
looking
and
the man looked at her and he said
you know just if you have kids i'm gonna
tell you yeah [ __ ] why don't you come
over here and sit on my crotch
now
that's what we're talking that is an
example of toxic masculinity that's a
man who had no respect for this woman
right
my relative got up and said what did you
say big guy size of my dad 62 220. i
said what did you say what did you say
and he started getting up in his face
and then his wife said no no stop stop
stop stop stop he said no what did you
what do you want to say that again the
guy was kinda getting a little bit
mouthy and his wife said hey stop stop
what would jesus do i swear to you and
he said
jesus got off three stops ago i'm about
to kick the [ __ ] out of this stuff
now
that's what i'm talking about are you
going to say to me that what my relative
did was just as immoral as a man on the
subway so let's clearly differentiate
the problem is you vilified all of it
yes of course it's a tenet of feminism
but also mothers be very very careful
when you are raising boys because i
think all boys have at some point been
admonished or realized there's just a
disconnect where sometimes mothers don't
understand that boy behavior is boy
behavior you need to bridle it you don't
want to try and snuff it out okay unless
you want a train full of men like we saw
today where this woman gets hit and
there's not a good there's not a single
good man so toxic masculinity runs
rampant when actual masculinity is not
encouraged and taught and fostered yes
that's the issue there a real man who is
aggressive who is assertive who is
confident who is loyal
punches the man hitting a woman
in the face
right
lazes lays his cloak down over a puddle
that's the idea why do you think why do
you think chivalry's dead that goes back
to uh goes back to dave's point
why do you think it's dead because
someone might open a door for you and be
accused of being a sexist cat calling
no one's supporting cat calling hey you
have beautiful eyes it's not a cat call
and you wonder why the dating pool isn't
so great okay and this is something else
too women have changed what they want in
men men used to want someone like my
relative men used to want a man who
would say hey you're beautiful men used
to want a man who was assertive sorry
women used to want a man who wasn't
served well you know i was confused
there for a second i was like
um
then women switch with post-modernism
saying actually we want a man who's
sensitive and in touch with his feelings
and more importantly in touch with our
feelings you don't want a man who's in
touch with your feelings you want a man
who listens to your feelings you don't
want a man who understands it from a
first person perspective
just like you don't want to understand
why your men's head is disgusting from a
first person perspective you want to
listen you don't want this
you don't want this you don't want it
you you want to support each other
but you really shouldn't understand it
firsthand and instead of
feminists and a lot of women have seen
it it's easier it's easier to have a to
have a house cat it's easier to have a
tamed horse than to have to tame a wild
one
but the reward is different and now you
have men who don't defend their wives in
subways okay men naturally want to solve
a problem where women you know
kind of want to talk yes
that's true
wow i just put that in a way that it did
not mean no it's as bad as it did thanks
ain't going to make
no i'm going to be in trouble
no i understand what you're saying
remember talk about their feelings
whereas men don't yeah well women don't
actually want that though their bodies
trust me i have a cousin who's a marine
he's like six three looks like matt
damon on steroids and women just will
like flock to him because of the natural
like wanting to be with a john wayne
type right what i mean and you see it
happen
these are the weirdest examples you
picked like five foot four matt damon
and john wayne who walked like he was at
a full hey fair john wayne was old man
son hey i'm gonna take you out sonny boy
john you know what i mean john wayne was
a man like the frankenstein auto play
halloween decoration
john wayne was a man i did the match
mash
in the monster so i mean he was a little
you know
lightning loafers
here's another complaint too i got to
keep going through this and thank you
for the likes that you guys because i do
want to make sure we're almost up to 40.
let's get a few more uh this is
something here women complain about now
once they reach a certain point well men
a lot of men don't want children anymore
that's actually what is that's actually
not true
i hate you kid
say wolf man
way too happy to be abusive yeah he's
like i got your backpack you piece of
[ __ ]
i'm surprised his hand wasn't like this
yeah i got you back
what do you want oh you want dunkaroo
yeah don't go through that
yeah that is cause my snack is dead
no here's the thing most of them don't
want to kiss him that's actually not
true most men don't want kids with you
that's something that is a really tough
pill to swell and by the way because of
leftist feminists this has affected all
women just so you know
just so you know all women are you're
saying not me
yes you're affected by it you may not
believe the things
that feminists have espoused
but you've allowed them to speak for you
and your community
for so long that now you have men with
no testosterone in their system and
transgenders flooding your lesbian
dating apps this is all from you we
didn't have a say in this
so men don't want children with you why
probably because most women are well
into their 30s before they even think
about it and they place a priority on
careers at this point that's not all
that interesting to men throw in a
lifetime of promiscuity on top of it
guess what guys will play the field in
college they don't want to marry a [ __ ]
what are you saying [ __ ] had sex with
lots of people
clear enough for you you may say i'm not
a [ __ ] great you say that men still
think you are
they don't want kids with you
what are you gonna you're gonna live
with a guy
you're gonna have five ten twenty sexual
partners
live with a guy before you get married
and then at 36 up and decide that you
want to have kids and wonder why he
thinks that's a bad bargain
you've given away all your chips
god i'm right here
and i hear something else too
men a lot of men think it's signing away
their life why because now a man looks a
man used to look at the prospect of
having kids okay
and a man used to look at this and say
okay i have a loyal wife a wife would
probably probably the woman of my youth
right high school sweetheart was very
common like your parents my parents got
to know each other very young i married
my wife you married your wife very
youngster you grow up together yeah
you're close with each other and then
used to be women stayed home took care
of the kids that was her job and you
went you brought home the bacon you came
home you played with the kids you spent
some time with them maybe took them to a
game and then you could recharge for the
next day but now the expectation is
somewhere in your 30s your woman is
going to work it's going to be a dual
household income you're going to work
all day as a man a man feels he's going
to work all day come home and then have
to be mr mom and he's going you know
what i'll just stay single and i don't
need that much money i can get a flex
job
yeah they've been let off the hook yeah
and we hold but going back to your last
example we hold men to the same standard
of course you know what i mean like men
are out sleeping around we don't we
don't look at that and clap i mean i
know the movies portray it that way but
that's not real i'm talking to the guy
who was condemned for writing about
abstinence to be clear it was said i was
told this is sexist how could you how
could you degrade women this way by not
having sex with them yeah
how dare you reject them you golden
penis syndrome yeah person it's almost
like you're the kind of [ __ ] who would
be offended if i held open the door
i feel like a real scumbag you really do
dave you've been sexist your whole life
i was totally monogamous with a bunch of
[ __ ]
i was monogamous at the time i mean
every one of them he had a rotating door
installed in his well
yeah and a slide on the other side of
the room i never knew it
it was just it was really more of a of a
revolving trebuchet that's slowing you
right into a vietnamese sex hammock oh
geez wow how did i what is this
hellraiser if you're gonna say
you know after vomiting who am i to say
no
all right here's another one too that we
have men are cheaters we've been
complaining about this quite a bit right
that men are cheaters you can bring up
that image there uh quarterback here
no or token
probably the uh no it's token anybody he
was just transferring that
uh i don't know if cheating has
increased uh statistically or not but um
it certainly seems like it's something
that people talk about in other words
it's something that men are more open
about uh
i don't know this is something you hear
what
feminists were you expecting monogamy
and fidelity i i don't i don't
understand this one i don't understand
how you can be upset about this when you
change the rules it'd be like uh jada
pinkett smith being mad that will
cheated yeah but that was the
arrangement with a woman yes
the whole idea though of monogamy
fidelity these these are traditional
christian values you you shunned them
you said that's awful that's the
patriarchy well great now you're with
the sexual revolution it's not cheating
it's the new it's the code of rules you
wrote
i i i
is it me no i don't even think this one
needs to be that long no it doesn't
here's the thing let me tell you
obviously let me tell you let me use
this as an example because you hear i
know that everyone's always a edgy
atheist now because it's the thing to do
um
maybe
maybe and you hear this a lot uh maybe
women out there feminist atheists uh
don't need a god to tell them not to
murder like oh
i don't need if you need a god to tell
you not to murder you're a horrible
person you hear that all the time okay
so maybe feminist atheists out there
right and this is obviously time when
you look at the sexual revolution it was
this idea of shunning christianity and
so you can call it pseudo-spirituality
which evolved into atheism whatever you
want to call it but certainly if you
look at the roots also where it's tied
with marxist theory and you understand
that that's the distinctly atheistic
ideology i'm not too far off base i
understand not all feminists are
atheists but most okay so maybe a
feminist atheist maybe female atheists
out there maybe you don't need a god to
tell you not to murder
i'll grant you that
but i tell you what
a straight man definitely needs a god to
tell him not to cheat on his wife
because let me tell you something that's
actually this idea that like
really everyone knows no no no not only
does everyone not know that infidelity
is wrong it was actually mocked and seen
as a weakness in every society almost
every society i don't want to misspeak
until modern christendom and still is in
the developing world
you're seen as impotent and a loser
unless you're banging everything you
possibly can
yeah
it's hard wired into your bodies you
have to control those types of things
and christianity gave us the ability to
control those types of things right you
may not need a god to tell you not to
steal you may not need a guy to tell you
not to murder by the way it's a [ __ ]
argument because there are tribes of
murder all the time the native americans
would kill women and children in scalp
and they didn't see any problem with it
they'd have concept of personal property
however let's say today you don't think
it's a byproduct of modern
judeo-christian society but feminists
say well i don't need i don't need a god
to tell me not to steal or kill straight
men absolutely need a god to tell them
not to cheat and to stay with one woman
period
nothing
and our hard wiring tells us to do that
yeah well society has also cheapened
what it is that is actually going on
when you have what we call an affair we
talked about this the other day and you
said in french that's kind of like a
thing
it just means it just kind of it's kind
of a throw i think no it's a physical
act with your penis and her vagina let's
just be very very clear of what's going
on here i'm not always exclusive it
could be you know that's depends on the
definition of is is but then but then we
have instances with say like a kobe
bryant or some famous athlete that goes
out there and does something that's
horrifically bad no i'm saying he does
something horrifically bad and we're
like oh but he's crashing a helicopter
no
it was it was called it's been a while
that's gonna i'm just saying like we
have we have looked over this what did
he did he did he i don't i don't follow
his horse did he he was sexually
assaulted somebody i don't know he was
accused of sexual assault but what he
did was cheating on his wife but he made
amends with it though no no i understand
that's what i like about kobe is he he
came clean about it and he switched to
the way that he was living around right
the point i i really opposed to magic
johnson yeah i agree okay he dies yeah
he's straight i'm not saying you're not
saying that i'm just saying kobe bryant
though the point is how the public
reacted right the public always reacts
oh well this person is our guy you can
shame anybody that you want that's the
problem yeah well and then you've got
people like jfk who's still lauded in
democratic circles and he's like he
would he would sleep with anything that
came through the white house marilyn
monroe slept with every kennedy except
ted
ted was the one left out ted was
swimming yeah he was a little
dangerous in the pool he was like how
about you uh bring that over here sing
me happy birthday yeah she thought
you're gross
benzos was a better idea than getting in
a car with him
no that's what we've done we've
cheapened in society what it means like
we've given people passes for this yeah
and we should never have given them
passes for this and you're right men can
make amends men can change how they live
men can make up for their mistakes so
i'm not saying that about kobe but
there's so many times where we just
turned a blind eye because bill clinton
he was our favorite player he was our
favorite politician he was our favorite
businessman we just turned a blind eye
to that it's not that big a deal right
what if you have that relationship with
somebody where you are allowed to do
that i mean because there are people
that yeah that's different but what i'm
saying is most women don't also more
most women yeah most women don't want
that most women aren't happy with do you
think two women at once is more i mean
in an open relationship is stupid
anybody would have to look at me from
behind and be like you're not gonna like
this well depends how big the women are
it might just be two women stuffing you
into a cubby oh my gosh
oh dragon test no they're just putting
you in i'm a little i want to be a
little koala
[Laughter]
so look i just think it's i just i
understand i understand why there's so
many different
yeah i don't know no there aren't many
different that's the thing that women as
women as a general rule they want
overwhelmingly the same things and now
they're frustrated women many of you are
frustrated that you aren't finding it
overwhelmingly want to have kids women
overwhelmingly find satisfaction want to
have a husband a husband who is faithful
to them women want to have a stable home
life and you know what it's unavailable
to you now because of for the same
reason that you had no control over the
[ __ ] your kids were learning until you
woke up this last year take an active
role this is a call out to
women out there to do
what men generally do i spoke with my
wife about this yesterday
she she said like oh make sure can you
speak uh when you ask uh i don't
remember what i don't want to out
anybody i always have to be careful
again because my my wife is like don't
discuss this well men are like you can
say whatever you want like can i pay hey
hey i'll be like hey uh a quarter black
can i tell them about that time you got
your dick caught in a meat grinder like
sure whatever yeah whereas fully
recovered hilarious don't tell them
about don't tell them about the fact
that you know i only have sex pair their
underwear whatever the hell it is it's
like no one cares
darkness and
here say nobody cares yeah so the issue
here was i said to my wife i said do you
have any idea how men talk with men
how we treat each other i said i think
you would be horrified if if
if i were to for example speak to you
the way that i speak with gerald or dave
i love gerald and i love dave i love
garrett but the way we talk with each
other and by the way do you know the
reason that i don't speak with my wife
that way
just just this is just the abcs of me
because the bible tells me i need to be
gentler and kinder with my wife why
because women are the kinder the gentler
and yes the weaker of the sexes
physically
more empathetic well the worst emotional
goofballs they are they're a little
they're a little silly come on goodness
oh come on laugh i want to see the i
want to see the ladies commenting in the
chat they know that i'm kidding i love i
love [ __ ] be shopping
i don't know what are you sorry about
spinback using the b word i'm bad no
here's another thing this is a funny
term to use while talking about and this
brings us to the end point as to how
crazy it's got now you have people
complaining women and this is a bit of a
straw man but it's just i needed one
more complaint to render out to seven uh
uh the dating pool is filled with
transgenders
just bring this up as an example this is
very important a lot of women now are
saying what happened to women-only
spaces you saw this in loudoun county
what was a 20-point switch because a boy
in a skirt raped a girl
well here's the other part that you
don't hear about that
guess who covered it up and guess who
didn't believe the girl
was a woman in a rainbow t-shirt the mom
of the boy in the skirt just came out
and said oh
this is actually true almost a direct
quote this just came out yesterday we
wrote about it on the website i'll
reference the bill letters credit.com
said oh if it was she was willing if it
was rape she'd be kicking screaming
anything to get rid of and it was
supposed to be if you have kids have
them leave now three two [ __ ] and it was
supposed to be vaginal it might have
been anal for 10 seconds and it was an
accident and then he was concerned about
her he and she actually said this he
touched her forehead
what does that mean you crazy coot he
touched her forehead it was women who
why the name of tolerance
said oh transgender bathroom policy and
i say this because there are a lot of
chickens that have come home to roost
here women guess what men have always
always
fixed this [ __ ] they have always
opposed biological men being in women's
bathrooms they have always opposed
biological men beating up on women in
sports and poll after poll after poll
shows a majority of women support it
until they start raping your kids
because it seems empathetic to go well
who am i and this is what's beautiful
about you
women are more empathetic women are
gentler women are kinder they do put
themselves in someone else's shoes
that's a good quality however you need
to be able to see around the bend and it
starts with however anyone wants to
identify regardless of science
regardless of biology and it ends with
women getting concussed in combat sports
and your daughter's being raped
and then a 20-point swing in the vote
guess what
we opposed it meaning we men
all along the trail of course the active
feminists supported it right third wave
feminism there are some who fight
against it but they've largely take most
of them are scared into silence through
being called a turf and that works on
women right it doesn't work on guys like
well i'm a turf what you mean that i
believe that a penis is a thing okay
whereas women go oh no turf i don't want
people to think i'm mean it's okay
it's okay
for people to think you're mean if you
know you're not doing it out of malice
but out of principle because you know
that someone with a [ __ ] shouldn't be in
your daughter's bathroom right and i
need to be clear because youtube gets a
little pissy on some of these things we
are not saying that transgender people
pose a significant threat to uh raping
all of your i said person
with a [ __ ] what exactly just to be
clear that could be
hey leftist that could be a man woman
your guess is as good as good good as
mine it's a 50 50 shot right i didn't
say transgender i said a person with a
[ __ ] and in this case it was a boy and a
skirt look there's a problem with it
because
anyone who is seeking to take advantage
of sorry weaker sex
in women's bathrooms in this case in
girls bathrooms whether they happen to
be transgender or they happen to be a
boy in a skirt taking advantage of the
policy it allows the predatory to take
advantage of the vulnerable yeah and yes
physically women are always more
vulnerable at the hands of a male
attacker than the average male notice
women aren't dominating in men's sports
biological women notice
you're not getting sexual assaults
taking place in men's bathrooms
from biological women
we don't even have a dog in that fight
the reason that men opposed it is
because we said this is going to be bad
for women why because we know
people who have penises biological men
we know how they think we know how they
act we know the risk that it poses to
you for the same reason that you've
accused us of being controlling we want
to make sure that you have your phone on
when you're out by yourself we want to
make sure that we know where you are
that you don't go into alleyways why
because good men
it's a double-edged sword but they want
to protect their women they want to
love their women and make sure that they
are safe it's almost like that's the
primary character trait that's important
and a husband
but you villavite that for a long time
so women let me just recap this and then
we'll go and take your chat so i know
this is a long show today it's a
marathon two marathon shows this week
um
women want a man who's more sensitive
right to get rid of toxic masculinity a
man who's in touch with his feminine
side they want a man who uh has a
college degree now they want a man who
uh makes more money than them on average
or a lot of these sort of conditions
that have been created versus back if
you look back in the 1950s they wanted a
man who was a protector provider you
know head of household good leader and
uh if you look at men what they want
today in 2021 it's the exact
it's
same
exact same
it hasn't changed
the primary gripes from men same as back
then uh i don't know if she's gonna work
why she's not hot enough physical
attraction important for men we're
visual animals
uh you know i don't know shouldn't seem
very nice
men want a woman who's attractive woman
who's nice kind nurturing loyal as a
wife by the way
income doesn't matter we don't care
sense of humor
as long as i can make you laugh we don't
have to share a sense of humor we have
to share interest in sports so we've all
been told that now right oh what do you
have in common guess who had very little
in common men and women since the
beginning of always up until the 1960s
it doesn't matter i don't want to marry
a drinking buddy
i want to marry a dame that's why i have
a wife i don't give a [ __ ] if she's a
fan of george st pierre
a matter of fact i'd be worried if she
was that into it
we've placed an emphasis on all the
wrong things and the truth is men still
want the same things in women that they
wanted 50 60 years ago and feminists
have allowed women you to be led by the
nose down a trail that leads to
well hopefully this trail continues
leading out of where you found
yourselves because i want women to be
happy i want women to be safe i want
them to be protected and you know what
virginia was a good start
let's try and build some real momentum
with that okay
and don't be guilted certainly not from
some racist [ __ ] on twitter all
right let's smash that like button one
last time you guys can comment below
this one went late today rumble 250.
thank you so much we appreciate it and
uh youtube
we appreciate you zero piss off
[Music]
you